[Applause]
some people move on but not us
not us hey everybody its charlie we got
a whole bunch of New Avengers and game
to break down there were a lot of
questions about weird shots in that
Avengers end game Super Bowl trailer so
this will be a video addressing all that
like Rockets new uniform that looks a
lot like the quantum armor that we've
been seeing all the concept art where
Thor is what's going on with new Asgard
and where some of the missing characters
are that we see in some of these really
big negative spaces that they've clearly
digitally altered we're still doing the
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Ironman moment on the video so
first big question Rockets new comic
book accurate uniform he is clearly
wearing the double breasted uniform from
the guardians of the galaxy comics so
everybody was going crazy on the trailer
he's also you know big question on where
he is opening this wooden door with the
cliff face behind him so we'll also
address that but the other thing too the
people are torn on is what's going on
with the color of his uniform because in
the comics it's blue and even if you
crank the brightness way up on this
image it doesn't totally clarify exactly
what color this is the way the light is
hitting it just makes it look like the
red grayish quantum armor that we've
been seeing all the concept art of but
the actual uniform that he's walking
around in isn't armor it's just a cloth
uniform so that the quantum
quote-unquote armor that we've been
seeing the concept art of is something
that he would wear on top of that this
is one of those shots that I think is
also a little misleading just based on
the way that it's colored time like it's
semi finished it'll either look
different or it will appear at all in
the finished movie you also had to keep
that in mind too that while they did
shoot a lot of this footage and it's
probably from their Avengers and game
shoots because they did shoot infinity
war and end game back-to-back so
sometimes you're not really sure about
what's deleted footage from infinity war
that we've never seen before in what's
actual footage from Avengers end game so
just keep in mind that a lot of the
trailers that we see for Avengers
endgame could include deleted scenes
from infinity war that they're trying to
pass off as if they're brand-new scenes
best option for where rocket is here is
it is a version of new Asgard or it's
Wakanda now obviously the water does
look a little bit different so I'd say
odds are pretty good that it could be
new Asgard in Norway just because of the
fishing right there next to the bay
remember from Thor Ragnarok where Odin
was sitting on
cliffside and said this would be a
wonderful place for Asgard that was sort
of the seed that he was planting for as
Gardea which is the name of new Asgard
when Thor rebuilds it on planet Earth
now in the comics it was in a very
different place I believe it was
somewhere in Oklahoma like it was in the
middle of the heartland of America so
the movies are already doing something
different with that but do remember that
a portion of the Asgardians escaped at
the beginning of infinity war before
Thanos showed up to kill everyone
so they Valkyrie in Korg were able to
get away with those as Guardians
this just may be the continuation of
that like okay the survivors have come
to create new Asgard and this is where
they're living in rocket rabbit has just
been hanging out with Thor a little bit
so that is also why when people saw Thor
in this shot here where people were like
where is he is he in Wakanda is he on
Santos's farm on new Titan that's the
name of the planet that he's on at the
end of infinity war it's a remade
version of Titan so it's not the
original planet Titan - just a new one
made to look like the original one so
you look in the background here this
isn't look exactly like the terrain of
new Asgard in that area Norway where he
was in a giant field but it could be
somewhere similar like that we did see
scenes of fan oohs in the last big
Avengers and game trailer walking
through his field with his armored
scarecrow obviously he's going to be
putting that back on during the film so
I think well at least visit it even if
the other Avengers don't go there
themselves looking for him but aside
from having very similar green terrain
there's nothing about this architecture
that screams fan OHS like you look at
the architecture of his ships it doesn't
look exactly like that and you look at
the interior of his cabin on his farm on
new Titan this doesn't look like that
either and even if you look at rock it
could see people like what if rocket is
also on Thanos form if you look in the
background of Thanos farm there's no
giant body of water or a cliff face or
anything like that so I think that's
also confirmation that rocket is not on
that planet in this shot if he really is
traveling around with Thor and early
parts in the film because remember we
all said this is probably from the first
15 to 20 minutes of the movie so this is
still when they're all picking up the
pieces and a little bit of time has gone
by next big question what is Hawkeye
looking at in that wreckage with the red
light on him very clearly he's found
something from outer space that looks
really weird he could be on another
planet even though I think we're gonna
see a lot of stuff happening in outer
space
I think a
out of the movie is gonna take place on
planet earth in a way that it did not
during infinity war because that was
largely them going to Titan and then
them going to Wakanda there been a lot
of rumors and behind-the-scenes shots
that we've seen it just seems like
they're revisiting a lot of beats from
the original Avengers movies from age of
Ultron from the first Avengers movie
there's that scene of Tony macgyvering
stuff from the first Iron Man movie most
of those movies took place in and around
planet Earth so we even though there's a
lot of crazy plot mechanics and
time-travel alternate realities quantum
realms stuff that we're talking about I
still think in a big sense a lot of it
will take place in and around planet
Earth so that would imply that Hawkeye
is on planet earth somewhere something
has crash-landed this could be one of
their allies showing up this could be
one of their enemies showing up I don't
think the Captain Marvel would crash
she's already proven that she's pretty
good with a flight stick and she can
also fly herself she's probably powerful
enough to fly through the vacuum of
space that entire distance but that just
kind of seems impractical so seems like
she was show up in a really cool-looking
spaceship so unless these are Scrolls or
shatori or Thanos showing up it's
probably Tony and nebula crashing as
they get back to earth but you can let
me know in the comments just based on
the look on his face do you think this
is friend or foe showing up in this
wreckage here there's a big question
about who's walking behind Rhodey in the
Avengers base like if you actually look
at this a couple more times and zoom in
zoom and enhance you can actually see a
figure walking behind war machine that's
a little bit shorter so odds are this is
actually banner who is still banner
wearing a new uniform that just has not
turned into the Hulk yet but that still
leaves the question of who is standing
in this negative space there's a couple
of shots like this in the trailer where
there's a weird amount of negative space
like there's a person that they just
photoshopped out because they don't want
you to know who's there so just keeping
with the idea that this is from the
first 15 to 20 minutes of the movie most
likely scenario is that the Captain
Marvel has not shown up yet and this is
Hawkeye because he's the only other like
brand new character that we know has not
come back to the Avengers base yet but
does show up in the first 15 to 20
minutes of the movie so right now he is
the best option but you guys can let me
know in this frame here like who is this
missing person that they photoshopped
out there's also the weirdly altered
shot of them outside in the middle of
the night of the Avengers based looking
at the sky like either something is
happening
or someone is arriving with a weird
amount of negative space like there's
clearly someone here that they have
photoshopped out look at the symmetry
and the way this shot is framed very
clearly there's meant to be someone
standing here so also carrying with the
theory this is from the first 15 to 20
minutes of the movie it's probably
either Ant Man or hawk-i and they're
either watching someone like Tony and
nebula or Captain Marvel arriving or
something is happening in this guy that
has something to do with ant man's
quantum realm and quantum energy planned
that he tries to pitch them like look at
where I've come from this is what's
going on after he gets the ketchup on
where everybody went why is no one
answering my phone calls
what are all these weird posters about
people being gone about why are there so
many empty cars in the streets did
everybody get raptured and they say no
they've been snap shirred and explained
thinness in the gauntlet to him lastly
they're really cool and probably one of
the best theories I've seen about the
Stan Lee cameo during the movie so
obviously Stan Lee does have a cameo
that he filmed for the movie before he
passed away so he will appear during it
I'm sure everybody's gonna cry a lot
when we actually find him in the film
theory now that he's actually one of
these older gentlemen the war veterans
that are sitting in this support circle
where Captain America is talking to them
like the shot where he's having that
grief counseling session like remember
Falcon used to do grief counseling for
military veterans and Captain America
visited during the Winter Soldier movie
there's a bunch of older military
veterans and remember that Stan Lee
during Avengers age of Ultron played a
World War 2 vet during that big party
scene he had like a really funny moment
where he said excelsior it got super
drunk he's not meant for mortal men
neither was Omaha Beach blondie stop
trying to scare us
eggshell shield totally possible that
he's reprising that character even
though technically he's an agent of the
Watchers so he's the same character in
all of his cameos but it would make more
sense that they call back to that war
veteran cameo from Avengers age of
Ultron and he plays the same character
sitting in the circle and in the way
that Stan Lee's cameos always do like
the spider-man into the spider-verse
cameo where he gives him the big call to
action the costumes always eventually
fit he gives Captain America a line like
that when he's talking about all the
grief about the people that they lost
the only other real being thing I saw
people confused about during the trailer
was that last line from Captain America
at the end of the trailer that sounded
kind of robotic as if it was someone
else I do think that it's still Chris
Evans playing a version of Captain
America but it's from a different part
of the film like obviously all the
dialogue is stitched together out of
context so I just think that he's saying
this not us line of dialogue when he's
either really tired or really hurt and
that's why it sounds different but it's
not like Ultron or someone mysteriously
pretending to be Captain America or any
crazy theory like that it's still
Captain America Chris Evans it just from
a very different part of the film but
just for fun post all the craziest
theories that you've heard or that
you've come up with after watching The
Avengers end game trailer but the other
big news is is that we finally heard
that they're casting a new version of
Wolverine eventually so I'll do a video
about new Wolverine later this week
leave your requests in the comments
below click here to re-watch the
Avengers end game trailer a billion more
times and click here for that Captain
Marvel Super Bowl trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]